[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance when you lose Rupert
Murdoch's son James have you lost
America probably not but how about when
you lose James Murdoch and Carl Icahn
how about when you lose James Murdoch
and Carl Icahn and the National
Basketball Association champion Golden
State Warriors and the chairman of
General Electric and the CEO of Disney
and of JPMorgan Chase and a 3 mm and of
Campbell Soup and of Merck and of Under
Armour and of Johnson of Johnson and at
Intel and at Blackrock and of Tesla and
the former CEO of uber and the president
of the afl-cio and the president of the
Alliance for American manufacturing and
all 16 members of the President's
Committee on the arts and humanities and
the Boy Scouts and the American Red
Cross fundraising gala scheduled for
merrill ago which they just decided to
move elsewhere and the American Cancer
Society fundraising gala that they just
moved out of mera Lago and the Susan G
Komen Foundation charity gala and the
Morse Life Health Systems charity gala
and the life leaders in furthering
education gala and the autism project of
Palm Beach County gala and the Salvation
Army fundraiser and the Palm Beach zoo
gala and the Dana Farber Cancer
Institute gala and the Leukemia and
Lymphoma Society gala and the Cleveland
Clinic gala and the American Friends of
Magen David Adom gala and the Backson
Palmer Eye Institute gala and the
Preservation Foundation of Palm Beach
gala and the shunned Orochi sue Food and
Wine Society annual dinner those are
some of the charities corporations
public figures CEOs presidential
Advisory Committee members and sports
franchises that have backed away in
nearly all cases just since Trump's
pathetic amoral performance in the wake
of Charlotte's ville backed away from
Donald John Trump the cliche the rats
are abandoning the sinking ship does not
apply here but only because these people
are not rats and because they appear to
have chartered a different ship so they
could get off the SS Trump panic in an
orderly and even stylish fashion
consider the actor Cowpen and the 15
other members of the President's
Committee on the arts and the humanities
which Trump claimed he had dissolve
right after they all quit the
resignation note the 16 of them signed
consists of five paragraphs which begin
with the words reproach elevating
speaking ignoring and supremacy the
first letter of each paragraph plus the
first letter in thank you
spells out the word resist that
basketball team the Golden State
Warriors they won their championship way
back on the 12th of June the team has
yet to be invited to the White House
which is believed to be a first since
Reagan was president but which is
probably a deft move actually because
the Warriors star Steph Curry already
says he would not go and after
Charlottesville a very plugged in San
Francisco Chronicle columnist same name
Scott Osler writes that he believes no
other player would go and the team
itself might even say no but of course
the charity gala is bailing out on Mara
Lago and there were more than 20
scheduled looks like there are around
half a dozen left including the Palm
Beach GOP and the Eric Trump foundation
they are the thing that will enrage
Trump the most none of this very public
backing away slowly from the tire fire
of this administration truly means
anything for the life of a presidency
polling suggests the hardline base for
Trump perhaps actually likes him more
after charlottesville made him bare his
soul the soul of a murderous clown or a
member of a hybrid party called the
Republic clans but as seen with the CEOs
and the charities it is the Stampede
quality that can have an impact
long-term it is called isolation in the
wake of the crowd rushing for the exits
and presumably in fear that none of the
attendees would show up Trump bailed out
of another presidential tradition
attending the Kennedy Center Honors Arts
Awards and saluting the winners at the
White House an isolated president
shunned by the public and real-life
leaders in all fields and of all
political stripes empowers those toadies
of 21st century America Republican
politicians to rebel at least
intermittently the Republicans senator
corker of Tennessee basically called
Trump unstable lass
weak Republican senators Scott of South
Carolina said Trump's moral authority is
compromised Trump's own government is
showing signs of peeling away from him
what happened to the transgender ban in
the military the one that heads of
several branches promptly repudiated
Trump keeps calling Russian electoral
interference fake news
the vice president described the country
speaking in a unified voice on sanctions
against Russia for electoral
interference Trump repeated is now
wearied hackney bleat about reopening
the investigation into the Hillary
Clinton emails the Deputy Attorney
General promptly said nothing is being
reopened there have even been cracks in
state-run propaganda on Fox News Charles
Krauthammer took Trump apart /
Charlottesville he called his formal
speech a quote hostage video another
conservative hit Trump so hard on Fox
she got death threats and somebody is
leaking the ugly details of trumps
people seemingly flat out paying for
good coverage from Fox News types and
their fellow travelers
The Washington Post managed to reveal
that Fox talking had mark serrano is the
owner of a firm that was reportedly paid
thirty thousand bucks in consulting fees
by Trump's twenty20 re-election
committee and then there's Tucker
Carlson second only to Sean Hannity
among foxes flying monkeys carrying the
propaganda to an ever-shrinking
right-wing TV audience the Center for
Media and democracy discovered that the
nutjob website that Carlson founded
called The Daily Caller
allegedly got a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars from the Trump campaign
last year for email blasts essentially
getting paid by the Trump campaign while
providing positive coverage of the Trump
campaign but again does this really mean
anything a Quinnipiac poll early this
month implied that even if Trump is
proved to have conspired with Russia on
the election proved as many as 70% of
Republicans really will not worry about
it
worse yet another poll reports that if
Trump claimed that he could not
guarantee that only eligible American
would be voting so the 2020 presidential
election needs to be postponed 52% of
Republicans would go along with him and
if Congress agreed with his fraud and
agreed with the suspension of the
democracy on this flimsiest of excuses
56% of Republicans would acquiesce to
postpone the election they won they
don't care how they don't care how he
plans to win again three years from now
but ultimately the answer to the
question do any of the public
repudiation and humiliations of Trump
matter in the real world outside the
Republican membership that may be a
qualified yes there are signs that they
do in combination with more meaningful
stuff like the seemingly slowing economy
and this Nazi nightmare and China and
Russia the president's instability and
Afghanistan not saying Steph Curry and
the Palm Beach zoo gala are driving this
but the newest polling by Marist
covering the week of Trump's
charlottesville disaster is i opening
his approval ratings in Michigan
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin 36 percent
Michigan 35 percent Pennsylvania 34
percent Wisconsin which party's
congressional candidate would you
support Democrats up by 13 Michigan up
by 10 Pennsylvania up by 8 Wisconsin has
Trump's conduct embarrassed you or made
you proud Michigan 64 embarrassed 28
proud Pennsylvania 63 embarrassed 25
proud Wisconsin 64 embarrassed 25 proud
hmm Michigan and Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin why those three states oh yes
those are the three states were a total
of 77 thousand votes swung the election
from clinton to trump where today he has
approval from just barely over one-third
of registered voters see it's not just
the celebrities and the ceos and the
charities who are running away from a
drowning president resist
remove peace